you
well I think what our mission right now
is you know with launching tilt and the
consulting that we do with our client
companies is really unlocking you know
human potential and improving quality of
life through Play and it's not I mean
there isn't a game in the world that
doesn't teach and there's no play style
even that doesn't teach so there is this
very human not not not a human need but
I mean it's a human it's just a human
facility this this play experience is
part of what we do so we're actually
going to see work and play get a lot
closer a lot closer together so we're
going to be playing more at work we're
actually going to be you know we're
actually going to have work that feels
more like like play so I predict that
not only do we have we're going to have
more robust enough simulations training
simulation games you know so if I you
know if I hand you a nuclear reactor you
know you can you can you can you can you
can play with it you can you can train
do you can do management training that
way you can do all kinds of social in
fact you know world of warcraft if
you're a little guild leader you know
you're learning a lot about management
managing other people so i think we're
going to see a lot of stuff happening in
in in games coming through and i think
I'm really hopeful for it was why I'm
sharing a lot of my research is that
what we're really helpful for is to see
huge changes in the American you know in
the American workplace and you know
actually all around the world because
when I go in and I'm you know I'm
trained to read emotion on people's
faces what I see and I see that and I
see their work styles and there you know
what tasks they can actually do and you
know I'm in awe and in horror of what I
see when I go into the average office
space because the work there is so I
mean it's so ill suited to the task at
hand you know if this were a zoo or a
kindergarten you know Child Protective
Services or you know the humane society
would be there down there you know to
close it down about an hour because the
the work environment the physical space
the types of tasks the emotions around
those tasks are totally ill suited to
accomplishing the task at hand and so by
I'm really understanding play what
motivates people and games are
self-motivating systems so
self-motivating systems we're going to
see that self-motivation permeate
throughout everything from word
processing to you know the way that your
copier operates we're going to see not
only that we're going to see the
game mechanics you know embedded in
embedded in the software that we use you
know in the physical devices that we
touch like you know a copy machine will
also see it in this business structures
as well so we're going to see the way
that we give feedback the way that we
give out tasks the way that we manage
folks is actually going to be a lot more
responsive to do game style kind of
thinking because in a game what do you
have to have well Sid Meier says it's
got to be interesting choices right so
you got to have that but then you also
you know I think that what we do in
games we really we simplify the world
you know we suspend some consequences
you know that gives us a little free
action and then we then enhance the
feedback and enhancing the feedback and
enhancing the reward that easy phone and
that that serious fun really can then
motivate folks motivate people to
explore and extend themselves and if
they when they accomplish something
cards they could do before then that
hard fun comes in and you feel much more
well-rounded as a person and much more
much more you know you feel much more
sent that sense of accomplishment and
you know really usefulness you know in
in society as large and actually just
riffing off of that a bit I think that
also the other way the games are
changing the way we are as a society is
it games have multi-variant inputs so
especially simulation games so you've
got multiple things coming in and you
have the ability to to to make a lot of
changes so in a sense simulation games
are really have the opportunity to
change the world to really educate us as
global citizens because what our
simulation games are they are a they
have multivariate inputs and
multivariant outputs so when I play
simcity I play a city manager and I you
make decisions you know and I can make
decisions you have related to Godzilla
or I can make decisions to earthquake or
fire or I can you build it up but when
you're done with SimCity you actually
know a little bit more about that you
know a minute more that world and what
do we need what we really need right now
are people who can understand
multi-variant systems to fight things
like global warming aids all these
problems we've pretty much dealt with a
lot of the low-hanging fruit here and so
you know i think the games play a really
serious role really important role in
elevating up our thinking to that next
level of play and i think if we can do
that the world will definitely be a
better place